SHARLENE CHIU:
I'm Sharlene Chiu.
And I'd like you to imagine
you're the mayor of Boston.
So let's say you want to reduce
energy consumption in the city.
That's a good goal to have.
So you're thinking about
passing different policies,
like reducing the number
of private vehicles
in the city center.
Now, thanks to this simulation
platform that my lab built,
you can actually take
your policy ideas
and simulate them in a
virtual city of Boston.
Now, even though you have this,
you have two more problems.
First is Boston could
change in 50 years.
The population could go down.
The fuel price could go up.
With all these
uncertainty factors,
you actually have way too many
possible futures scenarios
that Boston could enter.
And we just can't
simulate all of them.
It's too slow.
So I come in, and I
developed a technique
to help you figure out which
scenarios you want to test.
So my technique minimizes the
number of scenarios you need,
while also making sure that
you have enough scenarios
to represent the whole
possibility space.
So once you have
these scenarios,
you can take your
policies, your scenarios,
and stuff them into
the simulation.
And then you get numbers
out-- energy consumption.
And so you can actually
take these numbers
and see which policies
failed in which scenarios
and succeeded in
other scenarios.
But you'd like to know why they
failed and why they succeeded.
And so my second
part of the project
is helping you figure
out, what do scenarios
look like when a policy fails?
In doing so, you can
actually zoom in and say, OK,
as long as Boston avoids these
scenarios, you're good to go.
Or you can say,
let's actually dig
in to why everything fails when
population and ridesharing go
down.
Let's investigate that.
You have that option now.
And so at the end of
the day, my research
gave you a tool
to figure out what
to put into the
simulation, and a tool
to figure out what to do with
the numbers that come out
of the simulation.
And hopefully, that
gives you, the mayor,
a way to create better informed
decisions on which policies
you should pass.